welcome
so i thought i'd try a few game engines
for once and see if i can kind of get my
fill of programming with them
now i am a c plus plus programmer i
don't particularly like using
blueprints and nodes types workflow i
can it's okay but i really wanted to uh
try unreal
with the c plus plus development
but when i went to actually make a c
plus plus project in unreal five
i came across this little
error that basically said i didn't have
some version of net installed and then
some version of dot fx
and essentially it just didn't work
so here is the error
there it is and i did try to resolve
this i went in and installed that stuff
rebooted try it again same thing i think
it might have said it i needed something
else
i don't know why i have i'm pretty sure
i have all that stuff installed here we
go so i try unreal 4.26
just to see if hey maybe it's on real
five that's the problem so i put unreal
uh two six and c plus plus and try to
create same error so i give unity a go
let's give unity go maybe i can do some
scripting here i know it's c sharp
get in here with a new project and i
just search up scripting and unity and
look for a suitable tutorial to start
with now i probably don't want the
beginner stuff because i'm going to try
to teach you beginner programming stuff
and i'm a little bit past that so i go
for this some intermediate scripting and
this is where
i dive into some tutorials so i am going
to
walk you through a lot of this unity
stuff and you will probably learn a lot
about unity scripting by watching the
rest of this but if you really want to
learn go watch this free tutorial that's
on the screen now it's a lot longer and
more robust than what i'm going to say
here i'm basically going to give you
some quick overviews of what i learned
so in its most basic form all you do is
you create a script in your assets and
then you can end up attaching that to
any game object including an empty game
object if you just want it to exist in
your world
just go over here and click add
component choose a script or script
and that's basically how you get
the scripts going in
this engine and you can double click
them to open them
so in the first script of these
tutorials it basically has to make a
private and experience and as you set up
some getters and setters which they're
calling properties here they're sort of
like an automated
little getter setter system they have
and you can specify new variables like
this level here that returns based on
your experience and also has a set based
on your experience
and also you can go further with this
there's a little shortcut here which is
plain old get and set
if you don't want to do anything super
specific and just assign or get values
of course it actually needs a variable
to get in set which they didn't include
in the tutorial oddly enough
all right next we go over the ternary
operator which is exactly the same as c
plus plus it's basically an if else with
a little shortcut so we'll show a quick
example here
here's this is a live that basically
returns true if your health is over zero
or false otherwise
very straightforward example of a
ternary operator but
you can basically return one thing or
the other and it's a bit of a shortcut
optimization a lot of times
and to make things show up in unity
looks like you got to make them public
which makes sense but that doesn't work
for the properties only for the actual
variables it seems i thought it would
work for the whole properties thing too
but
okay so we went in here make sure it's
in there yep shows it and you can change
it right here in the editor so that's
kind of cool feature
next up on the list to learn was statics
statics work exactly as you would expect
same as in c plus plus
[Music]
in this example they have us create an
enemy script
and basically what we're going to do is
get rid of these
initial methods and
just store a static public static end of
the enemy count anytime we instantiate
an enemy increase this very common use
of static
just to keep track of how many are
initialized in the destructor you can
put a decrement too but i don't think
they go that far here
and they basically say you can do the
same thing with the player these are
pretty basic uses of static there's many
more advanced uses of static
but uh
yeah it's
it's static
for the players they do it on start
rather than on the constructor
as a way to check how many active
players are in the game or something
like that
and then we're gonna make another one
just a little player manager
and here we could also
do some stuff like
see how many players there are when we
start this player manager
and we'll make yet another file and this
is just
going to be a utilities example where
basically you can access this from other
classes so you can build
some functionality into here
like functions you commonly use and then
you can just use them from any of your
other scripts
and that's sort of a handy thing
there are some other things we want to
do to it like get rid of these other
methods here and we're going to end up
getting rid of mono behavior
and turn it into a static class
a class being static means it can't be
instantiated
and taking off this mono behavior
basically gets rid of the inheritance
from the unity stuff so
if we don't need that we get rid of it
[Music]
next we get into method overloading
this also works exactly as you would
think
basically the same as in c plus plus
where you can specify different types
that the function takes and that makes
it do
different things around a different
function
next we get into generics which are
basically templates
there's not really a whole lot to say
about these templates they mostly work
as you would think there are some
special things you can do like this
where at the end
this basically allows us to say has to
be a class or a struct which is a
variable or something else
and here we'll just show some examples
of putting these little templates to use
and next up on the scripting tutorial is
inheritance it works exactly as you
would think too about the same as c plus
plus the whole parent child relationship
and
public private protected
and also
the whole polymorphic features
it also has those so
we can cast and check things and
and call base constructors like that and
next we're going to look at polymorphism
because sometimes you want to know if
something is a so basically you can
check if a child has a parent class
and all that stuff pretty standard
polymorphic stuff now we're going to
talk a little about member hiding
now basically this is the use of this
new keyword to say that you use this
child classes function or value no
matter what so the parents i believe i
think that's all it does basically
[Music]
next we're going to look at overwriting
which is basically
creating uh functions in the child class
that override all the previous ones and
you can do some special tricks with that
this is pretty standard stuff here
and hey look you get points when you
complete these little tutorials
next we're going to look at interfaces
and kind of see what they do and how
they work
now basically these are just front ends
uh for some functionality but you still
got to build the functionality somewhere
so it's it's kind of like a promise
that these kind of things will
work but you can also go through
and check if something has an overloaded
method to see if you can call it
and next we're going to look at
extension methods
now these are methods that you can tack
on to a previous class
so it's a pretty neat little feature to
be able to just extend a class that
you're not allowed to
edit
and basically you just make a function
and you take in this which is the type
of class and you perform some operation
on this and it extends the class with
this new functionality pretty cool
what is the equivalent of this in c plus
plus
so then you can just call that on your
transform as you can see it even pops up
in the autocomplete stuff which should
be pretty handy and just see your
extensions next we're going to look at
namespaces these also do exactly what
you would think they're about the same
as they are at c plus plus but you also
get to them with the dot operator rather
than the double semicolon so that's a
little different
so next we're going to look at lists
and you might want to have a list of
something like that guys lists are like
linked lists or doubly linked lists in c
plus so they're very nice for adding and
removing data they can do that and they
can
resort themselves very quickly so that's
the nice thing about lists
but they're not necessarily contiguous
in memory so they can be a bit slow if
they get huge
[Music]
and then we're going to look at
dictionaries now dictionaries are
basically maps
you have a key which is the first value
string here and the second thing is what
that key points to and here we just have
a dictionary bad guys and
some examples of adding to it
so pretty standard map
stuff
and of course you can get to the value
you want by just putting in that key
and there are some try methods to see if
it exists but
these are pretty
slow next we're going to look at co
routines these basically allow you to do
something and yield return null until
it's finished so allow you to put like a
function within a function type of thing
and then next up we have some
quaternions yeah i looked over
quaternions no i'm not going to go over
them but it was actually a pretty good
little quick watch about them and then
delegates now delegates are something
like lambdas you can basically point
them to functions of the same signature
and they hold that so you can basically
change them on the fly as needed by
pointing them to a new function
and do all kinds of little tricky hacky
stuff with delegates
and switching them up as needed
to new functions
so uh yeah i don't know how i feel about
these they basically feel like weird
lambdas
lamb just created with the auto property
or something
you got to be careful about this
delicate keyword and the signature has
to be exact for anything you point it to
and you can plus add things to them or
minus things to them so they can
actually do multiple functions in a row
like this will do power up and then turn
red and then you can also check for noel
to see if there's anything actually
that's pointing to right now next we're
going to look at attributes
now these basically are for the unity
editor and they help you control
what it shows
and just like as a quick example here we
can put this speed within a range within
the syntax
and uh yeah you just basically put it
before it
and then over on the side you're going
to get the ability to have a slider for
it
here you see we can put execute and edit
mode on the class and then the script
will actually be running while you're in
edit mode
not sure how dangerous of a function
that is but
something you can do
[Music]
next up we're going to look at events
now events use delegates to
do some kind of actions so
here's an example of an on click
you can see here we've declared our
delegate which is a void that takes
nothing so that sort of click action
function that's going to assign to and
we have a
event here with the keyword
event
and we had a function down there but
we're going to assign it to teleport so
that when we click that button
we're going to do this
um teleport and as you can see the on
click you can plus or minus things from
it just like a delegate
you can also assign it multiple things
if you want so here we can also have
this turn color function
which is void and takes nothing
and that is pretty much everything that
the intermediate scripting went over
hope you enjoyed see you guys in the
next one peace out
[Music]
you